hello everyone and welcome to the
precision medicine virtual event my name
is Raj Samara I'm a global product
manager at Cajon and I will be
presenting on beyond the score tools for
pan biomarker analysis and can be
estimation in enabling deeper
understanding of somatic alterations
that contribute to cancer initiation
progression and recurrence please feel
free to submit questions during my
presentation and I will follow up with
you via email
just as a disclaimer the Kasich targeted
DNA panels are intended for molecular
biology applications only these products
are not intended for the diagnosis
prevention or treatment of a disease now
what I would like to go through in the
first part of this presentation is to go
through the the chemistry aspect of of a
pan-cancer and biomarker panel that we
have developed that can be used also for
40mb estimation and then my colleague
dieter will go over the bioinformatics
piece and just to start off with some
background about in your oncology and
therapies we anyone was was done and
work with with cancer understand the
hallmarks of cancer one of the hallmarks
be avoiding the new destruction and we
know that in oncology approaches to
modulate the immune system to promote
anti-tumor activity encounter at this
this hallmark however for in oncology
approaches to work very effectively they
need to incorporate an understanding and
Meccan of the mechanisms of tumor escape
within the tumor microenvironment so so
that's the first question that we always
want to answer is what is what is the
tumor microenvironment and basically the
tumor microenvironment is a living
organism it is an environment that
consists of many different types of
cells such as tumor cells tumor two
minutes of trading lymphocytes or tails
for short
and we know that tails have the
capability to kill tumor cells they get
primed in a lymph node they they have
the capability to infiltrate tumors
recognizing these tumor cells and we can
become and remain activated within the
student micro environment however we
know that the cells in this tumor
microenvironment are in constant
interactions with these we reach out
with each others and they can with each
other and they can sculpt each other's
activities and capabilities and we know
now from from several different
publications that tumor cells have
devised mechanisms to avoid in your
destruction this is one of the hallmarks
of cancer even in the presence of
activated codes so basically an
understanding of immunization within the
tumor microenvironment is going to be
key to advancing oncology research
you look at some examples of how how to
yourselves do this we know that AP cells
can recognize their target by binding to
the t-cell receptor by binding of the
t-cell receptor to antigens associated
with MHC class 1 molecules that are
presented on surface of all nucleated
cells so basically this this type of
binding of a tumor cell to two T cells
through these receptors will lead to the
activation of T cells and this is
represented on the right hand side of
the slide where you see that tumor cells
shown in yellow and the pre-social in
blue the interaction now between these
two these two different types of so see
the T cell receptor will lead to the
activation of T cells however we know
that immune checkpoint such as PB 1 have
they divided by Q cells to control their
activation T cells do not want to remain
in a constant activated state so they
divide these mechanisms of a checkpoint
such as PB 1 to control their activation
but we also know that tumor cells
Express PDL 1 which is a ligand that
binds to TD 1 and the binding of PDL 1 2
GB 1 TB 1 actually inhibits T cells T
cell function and this is shown on this
part of the of this of the presentation
whereby you see you see how PDL 1
The Binding of PDL 151 can actually link
to the inhibition of T cells and the
immunotherapy that has been devised so
far in the form of a QT bl1 antibodies
or a toxic area for antibodies they
actually block the interaction of T V 1
to Q L 1 and by blocking the interaction
of PD I want to key one you now have a
mechanism by which you can keep T cells
in an active format and a number of
immune checkpoints operate to control in
your system the PDL 1 PB 1 access is
only one on one of these forms and this
is actually shown on the next slide
there have been different types of alien
checkpoints discovered that actually
modulate the immune system as you see on
the under lower part of the slide in
green these are the sort of the
activation
pathways that lead to the activation of
two cells but on the top part of the
slide and read your student agreement
checkpoints and again PDR one and pd1
interaction is only one of these of
these in your checkpoints the other has
we investigate the checkpoint is ctla4
and by the binding of B seven one two to
ctla4 this is another checkpoint sort of
mechanism that has been devised to
inhibit through cell activation and
there are done there are a lot of other
indian checkpoints but for the sake of
of this presentation i'm using only PDI
one the interactions between PDI 1 and p
p1 as an example of this checkpoint then
again in you know oncology research has
been successfully translated to the
authorities in the clinic simply because
we understand how the the receptor lets
app1 and believe in PDL 1 interact and
lead to the inactivation of t-cells now
if you look at the different types of
immunotherapies that have been have been
approved so far there are missing four
of them over here with their generic
name and the brand name of your voice of
needle keeps redirect eccentric
along with their targets and you see
that the majority of them actually two
out of four target pd12 centric targets
PDL one and your voice argit's ctla4
along with their approval dates listed
on this slide and again keep in mind the
idea behind in the oncology therapies is
to prevent the the interaction between
the ligands such as pdq1
to its receptor that is expressed on
t-cells which is again in this case to
be one to keep these T cell active and
these different drugs have been approved
so I got some types of diseases such as
metastatic melanoma and non-small-cell
lung cancer and bladder cancer and so on
linear therapies again in the form of
checkpoint inhibitors have shown to have
been shown to be very effective in
treating a subset of these different
diseases again such as melanoma
non-small-cell lung cancer and bladder
cancer and a lot of questions have come
up as to why you know these types
of immunotherapies are effective and a
subset of the different cancers that we
see and what I will go in the next part
of this presentation is to kind of show
you why why these have been affected in
these types of cancers and not others
but before I get into this we now know
that in you know therapies are basically
a pillar of cancer treatments
traditionally cancer has been treated
with chemotherapy radiotherapy and
surgery but now immunotherapy is one of
those pillars of of cancer treatment and
they come in different flavors I've only
spoken about checkpoint inhibitors like
you know your voice that blocks the
interaction between ctla-4 its ligands
but there are other types of
immunotherapy such as cancer vaccines
and crusty cells but I won't go into
those in this presentation so I
mentioned that there are there are
specific cancers that actually respond
to the xenia therapies and immune
oncology drugs and again there have been
intensive research to try to answer the
question of why and this is shown
actually on this right here you this
year let's say for for instance for
colorectal cancer colorectal cancer
specimen specimens actually expressed
GDL one as you see on this slide on the
far right hand right hand side of this
table you know 53% of colorectal cancer
samples actually expressed ql1 and so if
they express PDL one generally speaking
or logically speaking they should be
responsive to the inhibition of PDL 1 2
and it's interaction with PB 1 however
you have not translated to to be
responsive in colorectal cancer but but
using good responses for other cancer
such as melanoma and not smoked
non-small cell lung cancer pavilion
cancer and what have you and again that
there have been a lot of efforts to try
to answer the question why not why do
you not see good responses for
colorectal cancer for instance when
these samples actually expressed to be L
1 and B 2 try to summarize everything
that has been done so far the reason
why is because examining one biomarker
or mechanism of action is not sufficient
to unlock the secrets of in the oncology
and in one needs to take an omics
approach in order to understand why
these tumors are responding or something
is are responding some tumors or not and
if you try to look at this omics
approach for new oncology
there are several sort of several
elements that that can be that can be
typed in in turn what is called anagram
which is basically all the different
elements that can be looked at in order
to understand you know responses to you
know therapies one of them is to know
mutational burden or qmb IMSI status i
want to look at lymphocyte counts one
can look at the repertoire a profile
that exists within within the tumor
microenvironment or so one can take a
look at gene expressions in terms of
effectors and inhibitors soluble
inhibitors to know metabolism and which
see expression antigen development coded
profiles
these are all elements that can be again
tied all together as in a cancer in
middlebrow and we know that NGS is the
ideal technology to for animal ecology
on its approach because you could use
the same technology to look at a lot of
these elements so we know that we could
use NGS to to assess PMD status test as
an aside status to look at you know two
cell receptors and understand and in
repertoires we can use MDS to look at
gene expression levels of different
sectors and inhibitors to examine your
antigens and their association with MHC
expression as well as microbial profile
so it is that ideal technology for this
immuno listen.you oncology omics
approach and one of elements that i will
focus on today is of course the TMB
mainly
MSI is won't be part of this
presentation but the focus is going to
be on PMD and how you could use a large
panel on that that has been developed to
be pan-cancer pan biomarker to also
assess to mutational burden status so
one but before I get into the solution
just a quick definition of what tmb is
and we all know that tmv is just
basically
the mutation mode in tumors we
understand and know that different types
of tumors Express a different number of
different number of mutations per
megabase so you see on the far right
hand side of this graph you see melanoma
lung and bladder and these are the
tumors that express the highest number
of mutations per megabase sequence but
you also see on the far left hand side
of this graph you see those those tumors
that do not express a large number of
mutations and so if you want to get to a
pure definition of tmb it's just
basically out of a million bases that
your sequence how many mutations do you
see
now in order to to address the sort of
the issue of trying to answer what is
the mutational tumor burden profile of a
specific sample we devised and have
developed a what is called the Chi su
PMD panel or the high speed
communication burden panel in order to
assess the TMV status of different
samples and the workflow of such a panel
is shown here at a very high level it
starts off with DNA that has been
extracted from biological samples and
the work will tolerate a little as 10
nanograms of DNA this is forward by
forming steps fragmentation using a
similar in dramatic reaction today
cyclists fragmented DNA into smaller
pieces and prepare prepare them for
library construction the second step is
live with construction and molecular
index assignments the workflow
incorporates um eyes or unique molecular
embassies or identifiers into the
original DNA molecules so that we can
track them with our by informatics
solutions and this is followed by target
enrichment using a single prime
extension approach will be enriched for
486 different genes by targeting our
exonic regions all of these primers that
are required for the enrichment have
been proved into an individual pool of
primers and then this is followed by
library amplification where you can
multiplex up to 384 samples for
sequencing run the entire workflow takes
about a day to go from extracted beyond
the samples all the way to library that
can be quantified in sequence
now the the solution or the approach
that we that we've built for for qmb
analysis and pan biomarker analysis in
different types of cancers is a sample
to insite approaching the in the sense
that we've taken not only the chemistry
but also the necessary bioinformatics
tools to allow you to analyze all of
that data coming out of the panel and we
package them into one solution so if you
look at the elements that are required
for 40mb analysis for instance you need
the TMT panel itself which contains the
proprietary PCL chemistry to enrich even
to see the fusions and primers that are
based on single primer extension
approach for enhanced uniformity the
panel box is sequence or agnostic in the
sense that the same chemistry can be
applied to different types of sequencers
like the Illumina sequencer so I in turn
sequencers the sequence or specificity
comes in at the index box Laveau beads
are this is another another box that is
required for the workflow and it
contains the molecular bar-coded library
adapters that incorporates uniqueness of
indices and of course you have the
analysis pipelines
these are barcode aware data analysis
pipelines that analyze the data and not
only Condor reads but also on you need
more parenthesis then in addition to to
do secondary analysis pipeline there are
interpretation 5 times as well and
solutions to allow you to they basically
make sense of all of the different areas
that detector just to kind of elaborate
a little bit under the 2 unique elements
that we built into the chemistry side of
this equation namely the single primer
extension approach and the ignore
indices you know what I'll do in the
next maybe three or four slides is to
give you sort of a sense of what what
single primer extension is all about and
what um eyes are all about and how they
are helpful for such an application so
for single primer extension based
enrichment what I want to do here is to
just compare it to the traditional a
pecan based approach that uses two
primers to define a specific region so
if you think about how we proficiently
do and
form amplicon days sequencing is to
define the regions of interest using two
region specific primers - just as an
example I'm using exon 21 of vgf or and
if you're using the 2 primer amplicon
design approach you would need to be to
define the exon 21 or GFR using two
primers that are specific to that exon
now the while this has been very
effectively for smaller for smaller
targets like SMD analysis or hot SWOT
analysis it has a lot of limitations
that some of the limitations are are
listed over here you have an increased
risk of primer dimers and dropouts just
because of the large number of primers
that will be required which will lead to
also lower uniformity and then multiple
primer pools are going to be required in
order to split those primers into into
different pools to maintain a specific
let's say library fragment size and it
also leads to lower like the complexity
because you are defining the start and
stop position of your amplicons and now
increasing the panel content might
require a complete you know primary
design of existing primers so let's say
you're using a panel of 400 genes today
and then you want to increase their the
content by adding another 5 genes the
additional primers that are required to
cover these additional 5 genes you know
what they will have to be basically
incorporated into your original panel
and now the primers of the original
panel might have to be redesigned so in
order to overcome these kinds of
challenges we've incorporated a single
primer extension approach for amplicon
design into the plastic panels and the
way a single primer extension approaches
work is very similar to the two primer
apples on design the biggest difference
is that your regions of interest are not
defined by two primers and more the
region of interest is defined by one
region specific primer the other primer
that is going to be required for for
enrichment and basically a universal
primer that binds two sequences
introducing the library adapters by
doing so we are reducing the number of
primers that are required for enrichment
and that allows us to reduce the risk of
primer dimers and
felt's it allows us to achieve a higher
degree of uniformity and now any a
single pool or primers will be required
for enrichment regardless of how large
that engine is this also leads to a
highlight the complexity because only
the start position is defined by that
range of specific primer the end
position is completely random and deep
it depends on only on the library
adapters and now increasing the panel
content does not require primary design
because you don't have because you've
eliminated or reduce the risk of primer
dimers and dropouts
so single primer extension is just
basically a way for us to to maintain
the benefits of amplicon sequencing but
also overcome the challenges that we see
with current approaches of amplicon
sequencing just to kind of give you a
sense of what unique molecular indices
are all about and how they are
beneficial for data analysis I'm going
to show you two examples of how we could
use unique molecular embassies for
accurate quantification and then on the
next slide it would be for a third
variant calling to consider the you know
the example shown or the Box shown on
the top part of the slide where you are
trying to quantify that they transcripts
mapping back to exon 21 of EGFR as a
surrogate you know for for EGFR
expression with conventional targeted
DNA or RNA sequencing approaches that
analyze data based on nonlinear Queens
if you have let's say five different you
know reads mapping back to exon 21 I do
GSR it is very difficult to to basically
differentiate between two scenarios of
having five unit DNA or RNA molecules or
quintuplets of the same DNA RNA molecule
basically looking at gives you are
duplicates so in the top part of the
slide you basically don't have a way to
not really differentiate between these
two different scenarios however if you
incorporate unique molecular indices
before any amplification takes place you
can now actually differentiate between
these two questions because this you as
you see on the bottom left of the slide
if you have five different um eyes
attached to these five different trans
that you know you've started off with
slightly transcripts and what you're
looking at or actually five transcripts
mapping back to excel to anyone over
EGFR but if you have the same unique
molecular index across these five
different reads then you know you you're
looking only at one unique molecule that
was just amplified over and over so
you're looking at PCR diffidence so what
this allows you to do now is to achieve
a higher level of quantification for for
these transcripts by incorporating these
molecular embassies and um eyes are also
important for accurate variant calling
and I'll use this sort of thing a very
similar example where we're looking at
mutations across exon 21 of EGFR and if
you only see let's say one mutation is
denoted by the red asterisk if you see
this one one mutation in five different
reads that not that - exon 21 of EGFR
you you don't have the necessary sort of
statistical power to to differentiate
between a too low frequency mutation
let's say that that is actually part of
exon 21 over here for in your in your
original biological sample or are you
looking at a PCR sequencing error
basically a false positive in your data
so with with your mines that have been
incorporated again before an
amplification takes place you can
actually now tell the difference between
a true of both frequency mutation and
accuracy or sequencing error by
examining than these unique molecular
embassies across all of those reads that
not back to that specific medium so on
the lower left hand left hand side of
the slide you see where you know we're
looking at a salsa variant because that
that specific variant that we're looking
at is actually part of five different
weeds that not back to exon 21 over GFR
that contain the same unique molecular
index if there was a crude mutation as
you see on the right hand side of that
box if it was a true low frequency
addition you should be able to see that
mutation in all of the leads that tell
us a unique molecular index because
they're coming you know from from the
same original molecule so by
incorporating these molecular indices
and analyzing data based on these
molecular industries you now have you
now have a way to differentiate between
what is a true low frequency mutation as
you see again on the right hand side of
the box the lower box or a PCR error as
you see on the left hand side of that
box
so just looking at quickly looking at
the the content of the chi 50mb panel
the chi security panel covers exon
inclusions of 486 genes and the genes
you know have been they belong to
different classes of biological
processes such as oncogenes tumor
suppressor genes cell cycle journeys
epigenetic genes and what-have-you
we've covered a wide range of biological
processes with this content and the
content itself is shown on this slide
but I won't go through every single gene
it is here for your reference looking at
some specifications as I mentioned it
covers 486 genes with more than 19,000
primers or an individual pool of primers
the number of target bases is about 1.3
million the types of variants that that
can be called or basically can be scores
snps in Delta copy number variants so
you can actually then it can use this
this type of content and panel not just
for kmb analysis but also to look at
different types of biomarkers specific
uniformity are listed here at 95.5% so
95.5% over we are specifically map back
to the regions of interest uniformity at
around 20 percent of the mean is
extremely high at ninety seven point
eight percent and the recommended DNA
input that we would recommend for can be
calling is 40 nano grams even though the
work so can tolerate down to 10
milligrams of input but if you're
interested in coding community scores
specifically we would recommend 40 nano
grams but utilize a single primer
extension for for enrichment and
incorporates unilateral indices and if
they're multiplexed up to 384 samples on
an Illumina instrument or up to 96
samples using ion torrent instruments
and then the total work for time is
eight to nine hours of course this
depends on the number of samples being
processed but you can go from extracted
DNA to libraries that can be quantified
and sequenced in eight to nine hours and
the very earliest frequency that you
could call it down 2.5%
and just to give you a sense of of
actual data coming out of this panel
specifically looking at tmb profiling or
candy status calling you know we've done
some some experiments internally as well
as with with some of our collaborators
to look at how does how do the scores
coming out of this panel how do they
correlate to scores coming out of some
sequencing approaches because that has
been doing sort of the gold standard for
can be calling and if you look at the
correlation between candy scores out of
the the candy panel as you see on the
y-axis and TMZ scores from home
sequencing projects on you can see on
the x-axis you do see a very nice
correlation between the two approaches
so you know that calling T on this
course from this from this chiastic
panel is going to be an extremely high
degree of correlation with um this
course called from exome sequencing
approaches but of course at a more
cost-effective fashion in a more
cost-effective fashion and not only do
we compare and correlate the scores
coming out of the panel with whole exome
sequencing a protein but we've also
compared them to scores coming out of
foundation one panels and we do see a
very nice degree of correlation between
the scores generated from the chiastic
panel and informatics solution with
foundation one scores and then also just
to look at the variation between site to
site we've run the same samples across
two different sites and when we look at
the different types of 2mg scores
generally did you see a high degree of
correlation between the first type in
the second site and so with this I will
end my part and I will turn it on to
Yatta
thank you so much right so uh we're
gonna shift here a little to focus on
the tertiary variant analysis which is
basically the last step in the NGS
sample to impact workflow and refers to
the interpretation reporting off
variance and I'm going to dive deeper
into project nickel insight interpret
the turkey analysis of solution
this is the disclaimer - clinical
insight interpret is also available at
clinical decision support software
so teach interpret enables labs to
deliver evidence-based insights for any
indication across rare hereditary
diseases territory campus oncology and T
Metro oncology so today we are going to
focus on how QC I interpret provides the
biological relevant insights into
various detected from comprehensive
cancer panel
you
so what is our title inside interpret so
this is at a high level and overview of
the various features of QC interpret PC
interpret assists in the classification
and reporting of alterations and it's
based on a comprehensive content
knowledge base which allows QC I to
display the alterations biology report
clinical cases prognostic outcomes
treatments and trials for the particular
alteration of interest in context of the
user entered disease phenotype
therefore the qci platform allows you to
answer important question what are the
biological characteristics of these
alterations is it clinically relevant
and is it actual PC I interpret computes
the biological relevance and
actionability according to the ACMG and
M guidelines for alteration
classification and because this removes
the need for time-consuming manual
research GGI provides labs with a
scalable automated interpretation
solution
the key I interpret platform provides
the user the option to customize the
final report and it can be configured to
watch the last specific needs which may
include lab specific reporting policies
test specific variant pre-filtering or
are the integration with other existing
laboratory pipelines all of that helps
the lab to automate standardized and
scale the NGS sequencing solution
so I thought panels are becoming
increasingly larger customers are
challenged by the increase in detected
mutations interpretation of more
biomarkers and an increase in novel
barrier customers are commonly receiving
VCS from the secondary pipeline that may
contain thousands of barriers and so
therefore labs using comprehensive kinds
of panels are challenged to prioritize
and interpret relevant actionable
mutations while ensuring a fast
turnaround time so qgi can be customized
vs test specific configuration which
enables consistent and scalable protease
ation of clinically relevant alterations
and this can be accomplished by a
customer miserable very pre-filter and I
show here decide a few of those options
that customers can select to narrow down
clinically relevant alteration
customizable preferred transcript
customizable reporting policies which
allows the automatic automatic reporting
of alterations treatments and trials
based on the laboratories reporting
policies and a customizable report so
this enables an automatic presentation
of relevant variants at scale
so one situation in general always
facing when interpreting the somatic
alteration
so you can see here as many resources
unnecessary for gathering information to
understand the biological relevance of
an alteration and that means we have to
sit through public or proprietary
databases to see if this variant has
been seen before in my disease context
and I just hired here a few handful
resources
so further we have to stick into
published literature that describes the
function of imitation its role in tumor
Genesis and association with the disease
and potential use of parent prediction
tools to predict the deleterious of the
mutation
then we also have to understand the
clinical relevance of an alteration so
it's the alteration relevant for
therapeutic prognostic or diagnostic
actionability and that means we have to
review the indications on drug labels
review constantly changing guideline
recommendations open clinical trials and
they dig into the primary articles that
provide insights into the extra bility
of an alteration
so there are challenges that we need to
overcome and I highlight a few of those
so the first one is efficiency so this
is a manual curation process that is
laborious and time-consuming the second
of a challenge is the accuracy as with
manual but with a manual process it can
be error-prone and especially if no
standardized curation protocols or and
semantic consistencies used
nano scalability the number of articles
that describe an article and an
alteration in the context of a disease
outcome or therapeutic response has
increased fourfold during the last ten
years and a lab would basically need to
hire an army of scientists to keep the
variant characteristics up-to-date which
leads to the challenge of being
comprehensive in content and content at
a reasonable amount of cost
the Teijin has simplified this process
by putting all this information in one
centralized location known as the kaijin
knowledge base so the kaijin knowledge
base holds more than 21 million findings
what that means is that those are this
is information that can be alterations
disease association or alteration direct
response associations and this is
stemming from more than 30,000
publications
sure enough to date knowledgebase the
content is updated mostly on a weekly
basis which allows us to cope with
increasing number of literature sources
and changing information from labels
trials and guidelines
the amount of external databases that
customers might need to review when
interpreting a variant is tremendous the
kaiser knowledgebase incorporates 31
external publicly or proprietary
databases and 25 of those are used in QC
interpret instance so with respect to
the therapeutic action bility as of
today we have more than 7,000 manually
curated alteration type direct response
disease associations across a variety of
indications that support the therapeutic
action ability inclusive interpret I
also want to point out that the
knowledgebase provides world wide open
and recruiting clinical trials where
biomarker require to us provide access
to biggest investigational drugs across
more than 110 genes in five minutes 30
indication
to assess the prognostic relevance of an
alteration which is of particular
interest for rather hematologic
malignancies the current knowledge base
covers content on a variety of different
cancer types
so what information specifically fuels
QC interpret and how is it possible that
QT interpret can match the evidence from
the literature to compute the alteration
classification in context of a specific
disease and this is accomplished through
a unique knowledge based model the one
you see here is that expert curators
which are PhD and MD levels read the
scientific literature including diggers
tables
supplementary information and add each
alteration clinical effect and drop
disease associations into a structured
format into the knowledge base and then
people will use natural language
processing to put the pieces of
information from the knowledge base
together into a sentence which returns
the essence of an experiment and
examples are for example functional
studies or clinical trial results from a
paper
so therefore unstructured data is
consistently structured with semantic
consistency in the ontology and this is
done across the different sources
so we can then apply rule based
algorithms on the structured data and a
knowledge base automatically trigger
pathogenicity criteria such as the ps3
or ps3 role for actionability TS such as
tier 1 year tier 1 8 to 1 B or T to D
you
the kiss I interpret is compliant with
the guidelines for interpreting
alterations the underlying guidelines to
assess the biological relevance are
based on the ACMG guidelines and then
cue to interpret provides the
actionability classification based on
the an Oscar cup guidelines
because assessing the pathogenicity and
axe ability of an alteration is
time-consuming manual research
keysight's capable for providing you
with the QC i computed classification of
this alteration
you
so now how is the information from the
knowledge base displayed in QC
Enterprise q so due to the limited time
I wanted to highlight here a few key
features that provide the actual or
biological insights into the alterations
detected in solid tumors so what you can
see on this slide is that this is a
parent list of an NGS result from a
stage 4 lung cancer sample
so each tile represents an alteration
detected in the tumor in the different
colors such as red or green display the
QC i computed pathogenicity of an
alteration and the letter such as 1a or
to see indicate the QC are computed
actionability classification
so if the panel was designed for
determining the TMV score for msi status
the user will be able to review the data
in the header of the test
so this view basically provides a broad
overview of the patient's molecular
profiles and allows various filtering to
portrays the alteration that would need
a deeper review
so if you will click on a tile it would
allow the user to rapidly assess the
biological relevance of the alteration
so within of each very detailed section
BCI provides front and center and
assessment section which displays the
actionability criteria and pathogenicity
criteria that are automated the
automatically triggers by QC interpret
the users able to immediately review the
description of the ACMG criteria as well
as review the underlying scientific
evidence that support the criteria
the one thing to note is that the user
has still full control of adjusting the
pathogenicity criteria by removing or
adding criterion or adjusting the
strength of the criteria and adding any
notes why this was done but that's
provides to you the full control over
determining the final pathogenicity
assessment
so in this example the functional
consequences of an alteration can be
easily set by clicking on the info icon
to gain a snapshot if this alteration
has been characterized in the literature
after reviewing the underlying evidence
of the ps3 rule which refers to
established in vitro on vevo functional
essays the user can review the
underlying publications but also look at
the location of the alteration if it's
falling into an important functional
domain or in an exome relative to the
whole gene
you
so for those alterations where the
function of the alteration is less clear
Li Association of a specific mutation
and the disease of interest might be
another way to shed more light into the
role of the mutation in this case the
user has the ability to review the
alteration Association within the
context of the disease in the assessment
section as well as in more details in
the recorded clinical case section
system
focusing on the actionability tears all
tears that are clickable will be shown
in the assessment section for each tier
the underlying clinical evidence can be
viewed and provides transparency in the
sources that support each tier
for the therapeutic activity the user
can go and deep dive into the treatment
section which lists treatment and
associates level of evidence in the
context of the specific operation and
the tumor type the section allows you
also to choose the associate treatment
and trial to be added to the planning
report
just to know the user has again full
flexibility to filter down clinical
trials according to the specificity
location and face and then select those
for inclusion on the final report
doctor reviewing the information in the
variant details page the user is able to
set the final assessment of the
alteration in this section do user have
the ability to report us pathogenicity
or action bilities for each alteration
before generating a final report the
review report page provides you with a
summary of the information locked as
reportable during the assessment process
which provides features to complete the
report building process manage and
review process and generate a report
so for our operations that are marked as
reportable qci can generate an
interpretive comment which contains
information about the gene operations
function and the therapeutic relevance
which saves the user time-consuming
manual work the users also able to
review our they reported drugs and
review PCI generated drug comments which
can be edited as well
so then we have a change state button
that allows you to manage the review
process on the test and then when the
report is ready for the sign-off process
you can click on the sign up button that
public page
last but not least before signing out
you might want to review the final
report
so this is a fully customizable of final
report and that basically shows relevant
parent information including the ACMG
pathogenicity and amp actionability
relevant drugs and trials I also want to
highlight here is that for that cute
interpret will provide front and center
on the final report the TMV score and
the image I status if those were
determined during the secondary analysis
if
d c---eight record results have been
validated by various laboratories which
compared to QC I completed
classification to my expert review and I
wanted to draw your attention to the
right side of the slide in this up study
a lab highlighted the time-saving aspect
when analyzing rare variants and they
estimated across 50 patient samples time
savings of up to 78% when using to see
interpret compared to expert clinical
genetic creations in large panels
so to summarize the key values of PC
interpret any lab Kennedy's immediately
adopt the ACMG or amp guidelines for
interpretation and recording Qi computes
the those guidelines for somatic
alterations classification which
provides the lab scalable standardized
alteration interpretation and reporting
solution
dai provides for each classification
full transparency to every piece of
scientific evidence it is a considerable
platform that provides customizable
reporting and it has flexible
integration with lab systems for
seamless interpretation workflow and
therefore kisi I interpret enables fast
analysis of results through scaleable
alterations interpretation and reporting
thank you so much for your attention